okay so we'll begin the first session
after lunch thank you for the
introduction and hi everyone my name is
Holly drew as I mentioned I'm currently
an assistant professor at the University
of Minnesota but I'm joining the
human-computer interaction Institute at
Carnegie Mellon University this fall
today I'm going to talk about the
bridging AI and HCI incorporating human
values into the development of AI
technologies so as we all know today's
thing the whole workshop scene is a
recent development in research
unfairness so a lot of machine learning
based systems are increasingly using a
lot of everyday services and
particularly in some very high stakes
position making contact such as criminal
justice and child protection so there is
the increasingly like a growing
attention to the issue of fairness in
such systems so speaking of the recent
development so in a recent paper
actually published in 2018 and three
researchers from University College
London and the University of Oxford and
interviewed 27 public sector machine
learning practitioners across five
different countries regarding the
challenges of understanding and
incorporating like a fairness into their
everyday work everyday work in terms of
like building actual machine learning
systems to assist to those like a
high-stake decision makings and this is
what they found in their paper so they
this is what they wrote that the
interview results suggest a disconnect
between the organizational and
institutional reality constraints and
needs and those addressed by current
research into useable transparent and
discrimination of where machine learning
absence is likely to undermine practical
practical initiatives unless addressed
so they provided a lot more details and
in their paper basically what they are
saying that the
so these like fairness aware machine
learning methods are built in isolation
both from the specific stakeholders and
their needs the actual values and the
context where the system is embedded so
my background I about my power I am a
human-computer interaction researcher so
we as a group of HCI researchers what we
do is to study the setting in which the
computing technology is embedded and the
needs and values of people in these
settings and in order to design like a
better computer computing technologies
so we have the tools to try to
potentially can maybe address and close
the gap so this is also like my primary
interest and my my research interest is
to study design and evaluating
intelligent systems in the real world
and the goal is to like create more fair
accountable like better like intelligent
systems so based on my recent study and
this is my provocation and it is
fairness is not the only human value
that we need to consider in the design
of AI systems so fairness is still
extremely important but we realize that
in order for this AI system to actually
work and we need to consider a wide
range of human values including fairness
and we and the challenges is how we can
incorporate this multiple stakeholder
value in the design and potentially
balance balance these different
stakeholder values especially when they
are conflicting with each other so my
talk today will be organized in this way
and I will first talk about one of our
recent project on creating deploying and
variety and intelligent recruitment
system in Wikipedia and specifically I
will talk about how we address the
challenge of incorporating and the
balancing multiple stakeholders values
and next I will talk about some our
ongoing work like the redesigning the AI
pace
the college control systems you know
Wikipedia oh I will talk about it the
next slide oh maybe next few slides okay
and the second working is actually
collaboration work with Steven who
organizer of this workshop and finally I
will talk about there the big picture
yes super to answer the question so
first Wikipedia I guess everyone here
knows what HPD is and Wikipedia is the
largest encyclopedia in human history
but what interests me most is it's not
just an encyclopedia it is the largest a
collaborative project in human history
so one thing I have been exploring since
my PhD is how Wikipedia community
actually manages this hundreds of
millions of born here contributors from
all over the world with very different
backgrounds expertise in the interests
and to achieve a common goal which is
write a coherent and consistent
encyclopedia and what we found in my PhD
work is like there is an important like
a nested organizational structure inside
the Wikipedia community which are called
wiki project and this wiki project play
an important role in managers activities
in the whole community so just like
America has like a 50 states and the
Wikipedia Wikipedia community actually
have hundreds of like active subgroups
ecology projects which help govern the
activities of millions of one-year
workers and we I found that these wiki
projects are important like
socialization and management hubs in
Wikipedia communities and these editors
they can seek help and find
collaborators and these new members
learn from the experience members and
they actually can guide and organize
these projects a group have these
mechanisms to guide and organize editors
work and they also wiki project offer
the protection against unwarranted
reverts and enter was but we also found
from our like data and from our work is
that so there is like recent decline
of these like a wiki projects and a lot
of booty projects like sort of a
struggling because of the shortage of
newcomers so we this is something that
like concerns the Wikimedia Foundation
which is organization that is like
maintain the site and we have been
discussing about how to like address and
identify these like new members for the
for the wiki project however identifying
like a new people who are suitable for
these wiki projects is not a trivial
task so as of July 2017 the English
Wikipedia alone has about 500 active
wiki projects covering about 3.6 meaning
articles and there are about 2.9 many
others who had more than 10 edits in in
the editing history which period in
history and there are about a thirty
eight thousand the new enters
registering the site our monthly basis
so and so the next thing we can think
about is maybe we can actually design
and eat intelligent a recruitment system
to help this wikiprojects to
automatically identify recruit and
retain these like suitable new members
so this is this is the goal of this
project however creating or recruitment
systems is inherently a quite
challenging job I tried quite
challenging tasks and we also heard
about like Amazon has actually been done
it's like a recruiting tools which we're
like biased against the female
applicants so one of the like chant
inherent challenges that it's there is
no clear ground choose so it's not clear
like who is actually suitable for this
job of all for these groups or not
and it is particularly challenging to
build this intelligence systems in the
context of Wikipedia due to the
community ax acceptance to the AI
technologies after our collaborator
Aaron half-acre wrote this paper talks
about this like early like AI
technologies in early days in the okiya
community and he concludes that the AI
tools fail a lot of AI tools build for
Wikipedia community failed because they
are insensitive to the contributors
motivations and the community values
and what makes designing intelligent
tools for the Wikipedia community even
more challenging is the like the recent
tension between the Wikipedia community
and the research community so research
that performs like offline analysis of
article content and the editor action
actions is typically not controversial
for example if you want to create like a
word to Veck like a bass songs that
Wikipedia corpus it is completely not
controversial at all however the
community tend to react strongly to
studies that will involve Dakota
interventions so studies that according
to their own word will affect
Wikipedia's natural state and the world
often encounter resistance from the
communities so after an experimental
study experiment study like conducted by
researchers from MIT and the University
of Pittsburgh in 2017 actually received
strong pushback from community which led
to the blocking of the research accounts
months months of heated discussion in
the Wikipedia community and an creation
of new policy New York a period called
Wikipedia is not a laboratory and this
Wikipedia editor actually precisely
described like what the Wikipedia
community wants so this is actual
comment another controversial research
like a proposal which was eventually
withdraw due to their strong pushback
from the community so this area said if
this proposal was an earnest effort to
improve mocha period the researchers
would have worked with the community
from the start to design studies and
will consistent with our needs and
values so this is what the Wikipedia
community wants they
go ahead sorry so when you say
intervention does not mean automated
editing or experimental editing of yes
so they anything that is not like a
external to the community so the things
that you just described is like editing
like making additional edits like for
example the studies MIT people Anna
University feasible to is like they will
have some people to edit half of the
articles but like leaving the other half
of article has control so they want to
see what kind of like edits will like I
have an effect so and anything like what
we do is also intervention so we are
going to create this new like
recruitment systems in to put it
deployed in Wikipedia and to although we
are arguing that or we are doing this
for your own good but they're what they
want is that to do something that
anything that conduct in Wikipedia had
to be really consistent with their needs
and values so don't mind sort of
read-only research so they I will talk
about that a little bit so actually
there is also discussions like in inside
Wikipedia community some people like
strongly say that we do not need any
research at all but then there are other
people saying that oh there are still
like group of researchers who are doing
something that really will benefit our
communities we should not ban and like
everything and which I'm going to talk
about at the end so it's like our study
actually have some positive effects the
relationship between the research
community
what about things like translations
automated translation Almeda translation
yes so they are actually also using
these tools for translations so using
tools as translations it's in January
fine because they will but they still
want human to like edit of the actually
translate yeah this is translation
before you actually put on they're like
oh you put on the Wikipedia and they
also wonder if you do but they do like
if you are doing this it's fine if you
do it like a long so it's like every
time I translate I first like use the
machine like learning transcription
systems and that and in my edit before
put out but if you are going to do it a
large scale then you need to get a pro
which one actually has automated the
ways of generating pages and generating
maybe translations yeah so that's
another good point so it's like right
now Wikipedia has about like a 50
different language like editions so
every individual like a Wikipedia like a
language Edition is its own community so
now I'm focusing on their like English
Wikipedia so English Wikipedia has this
policy so if they're creepy there is no
laboratory and they really if you are
going to do something you need to do
something that consistent where there
are values and needs so you know the
truth like when we think through like
satisfying these community needs and
values we also identify additional
challenges so a recruitment system that
we are operating in Wikipedia actually
involves multiple stakeholders so there
are like new people's to newcomers to
wiki projects and there are like current
project members and there are like a
Wikipedia as a whole and they want
different things
so these like newcomers through key
projects and according to the interviews
and surveys and they told us that they
value mentorship they want someone find
the mentors in the project they were
they liked the value mutual interest
they want to join a project that align
with their own like editing interest and
but for the current project members they
value productivity so they want to
recruit people who eventually come and
then like actually be productive and the
kind of worker project members this they
also mentioned it's important to
maintain the control of their wiki
projects now we also talked to like
Wikipedia like administrator in
Wikipedia they value like long-term
growth of the Wikipedia community and
one thing that particular mentioned is
the new pitner new member protection so
I will spend a little bit more time
talking about new member protection
because this is closely related to the
fairness so historically
like a new member groups new editor
groups are like a disadvantaged group in
Wikipedia because they tend to be
mistreated by the algorithmic tools so I
refer them for a quality control like a
system that has been deployed in
Wikipedia community for a couple of
years and eventually turned out that it
harmed the motivations of a lot of new
contributors who are still learning how
to participate so putting a technical
term it's just the false negative rate
is extremely high for these new editors
as a result a lot of newcomers just left
the communities and when their edits
were rudely reverted by the quality
control systems so you know which
eventually harms the overall growth of
the Wikipedia community so they really
want us like when we create these tools
we want to protect these like new
editors
so the question we're trying to ask is
how can we design the intelligence
recruitment system that can align with
these multiple stakeholders needs and
values so when we talking about like
intelligence system like algorithm is
essential for a component for any
intelligent systems but the traditional
approach is root to designer algorithm
it's basically precisely define the
inputs outputs and the designer property
of the system and abstracting away all
this complicated multi stakeholder
contacts this complex human needs and
values and so we argue that like this
like a pro trying to extracting a lot of
this like messy real world is probably
not capable of really capturing this
wide range of stakeholder value so what
we propose is that to really trying to
integrate this like complicated
multicast multi stakeholder contacts in
the design
oh we just design the algorithm in this
complicated real world
so the key of this issue to solution is
to shift away from solution oriented
approach to a process oriented one which
I'm going to talk more here so we
published this paper at GSD double to
some 18 so in this paper we propose
approach to actually consider these
different stakeholder value in the
design of of the algorithm so the first
step is record like we need to talk to
the stakeholders we need to understand
their values so instead of like creating
any like algorithm being a closed door
like in the lab we need to first like to
talk to the people and understand what
their values and needs are and the sidon
step is to like a base on these
understanding we want to use this
understanding to inform the design in
our initial algorithm and then the third
step is to trying to again go out to the
real world and to pilot testing and
deploy these algorithm so with the
stakeholders and we want to evaluate and
iteratively refine the average
based on their feedback so I'm going to
walk through these steps on how we use
this like four steps to create the
recruitment system you keep here so
first to understand the stakeholder
values so we as I mentioned actually
earlier so we identify these three
different stakeholders in the province
and then with the five values like
broadly as like what a personal group of
people consider important in life and we
sometimes user terms like motivations
perspective needs and interesting to
change beliefs and then we we want to
use these stakeholders values to guide
the creation of algorithm and we think
that when we create an algorithm so we
should not only consider like a at risk
make approaches specifically in our
cases like how to determine the fit
between the like a new member and the
project so the reason is that the
algorithm cannot be isolated from the
data the fuse a our algorithm and the
way how the algorithm is is presented so
in our particular case so we think like
data preparation like specifically like
whose we include in the like a data
preparation is really important because
it determines who our recruitment system
will target and also it's important to
consider how to present the results to
the stakeholders that is to whom we
should communicate the average of the
output and the user interface for
presenting these algorithms outcome
so we conduct a literature review and
the survey to identify the stakeholder
values and how the major choices in data
preparation algorithmic approaches and
output presentation how they like a
benefit or harm the different
stakeholder values so there is I know
there are a lot of information some of
this side I'm not going to expecting to
read all of them I will give you some
examples of how we use this table to
come up with creation that I will go
ahead
you don't include Wikipedia users and
all readers yes yes good point so yes we
didn't like talked to like like readers
you know for your case so one thing is
like Wikipedia like as a whole we
recorded like all these like I
represented by the administrators they
do consider a lot about like their
readers and and so we instead of think
that like we also trying to like to find
some readers but since they are like not
familiar with the whole editing like a
community and ecosystem so they will not
being able to provide like very helpful
suggestions and like how these things
work but yeah I think it's I guess like
this is indeed like first we think like
a readers like interests are sort of
implied or like increasingly there when
we interview with these like Wikipedia
administrators so to understand the goal
of Wikipedia oho but certainly is some
readers they just order at least a few
of them we talk to they just could not
be be very helpful any question what
cool people are you recruiting from so
they are already editors in Wikipedia
but they haven't drawn any wiki project
yeah but then yeah I'm going to talk
more detail about like even among these
people so great question I will talk
about okay so so wiki project so that's
another thing so you're like oh
organically so like any people they
can't like go to a wiki projects and put
their names like you know like a project
member list and stay that oh I
self-identified that I'm a member but
our recruitment system well which I'm
going to talk more details it's like we
will send this in recommendations to the
project organizers and these organizers
will invite these new people to join
their wiki projects but that's actually
a decision like after we're considering
like a different stakeholders and they
will make that so based on these I'm
like understanding of the different
stakeholder values we all know we create
the initial
algorithm so I will first talk about
like how we like balance this value
thing regarding the data preparation
which is who to include so I think we
will include we include and who to
basically recruit from so we will
recruit this error from the Audis like a
new people who are who are all the
editors who haven't drawn any wiki
projects but these people they still
vary a lot in terms they're like overall
experience in Wikipedia community
some of them might already be there for
a while are very experienced but some of
them are like a brand new editors so
what we found is that the stakeholders
really disagree on whether the algorithm
should target brand new editors so we
found that a lot of current project
members they just don't like this brand
new like newbies they're like they
prefer people with experience to think
that when you like a recruit this new
new people they well they won't be
productive after they joined the project
however as Wikipedia as a whole and they
told us it's extremely important to
retain these brand new editors so
actually so the lower retention of new
editor has result in an overall decline
in the active database
this is one of the like primary golf or
Wikimedia Foundation is trying to retain
this brand new editors so to address
this tension between the different
stakeholders so we implemented called in
multiple design to handle the varying
preferences among stakeholders
specifically we included both the brand
new editors and experienced the editors
in the data preparations but we also
like ranked they erect these two types
of editors separately so that these new
people do not like won't be like
overshadowed by the experienced ones and
then the second consideration is about
the a brisk approach how to determine
the feet so we conducted data analysis
on hundreds of southern so Wikipedia
editors they're looking at their prior
history they're looking at their like a
participation in the wiki projects and
we identify like two major ways to
determine the feet between new camera
and the project which is interest based
and the other one is the relationship
based so the interest space-wise folk
songs are like the interest alignment
between the new camera and the project
and the relationship focus on the
existing social connections or personal
connections between newcomers and the
current members of wiki project and
however when we talk to these
stakeholders they they again again they
disagree and now this time is disagree
about or the whether we should use a
relationship based a match or not so the
a lot of these current project members
they are saying that oh we're not very
sure if the people who we recruit from
based on this relation but relational
based approach will actually be like
interested and be productive like when
they join the project however those
newcomers they tend to like they told us
they will feel much more comfortable or
comfortable if they can join our project
that they already have some relationship
between the current member of the
project and as a result we decide to
actually
balance these different stakeholders
like values and interests and we
implement both the interest based and
the relationship based algorithm so we
created four different algorithms to
interest-based and to relationship based
and the first interest based average is
a rule based algorithm we simply
computed the number of edits these
editors made to the you know articles
within the scope of which would be
project so it's a very simple and
straightforward like a metric and the
second interest based algorithm is
called the category category based
algorithm so we computed similarity
score between the editors adding
histories and the topic of all key
projects we also created two
relationship based algorithms so one we
called it bump based algorithm so we
calculate there the the social
connections between the newcomers and
the current a member of project specific
will look at the number of messages they
send like on the wiki project top pages
Wikipedia top pages like how they so
between the new people and the existing
people of old key projects we also are
crater Coweta based the algorithm which
is computed like similarity of the edit
histories of the newcomers to the Edit
histories of all the current members of
a wiki project
and the last thing the final thing we'll
consider about is how to communicate the
algorithms output so there are two like
major options so we can go with so why
is to directly invite the newcomers and
the O is to communicate with the current
members first and based on like what we
talk with our stakeholders and these
current project members they feel
actually very strongly about like
directly inviting newcomers and they
they don't want us to directly invite
these new people and the reason they
told us that they want to be in the loop
and they is they want to maintain
control of the inviting process so you
therefore like instead of directly
inviting these potential new members we
create a user interface for presenting
the algorithm outputs to the current
project members and we present the top
recommendation from all four algorithms
separating experience editors and the
brand new editor this is how the
interface looks like this is the
interface was implemented as an
interactive table Wikipedia page and
they will include the basic information
about each candidate editors we also add
like simple explanations on why we
recommend this new editor to your group
and then we have this invite link so
they can directly click it and then
invite the new people to join their wiki
projects also have this short surveys to
like get there--like ratings to the
recommended quality of the
recommendations and they can also
provide some like any kind of feedback
now with this algorithm and like an
interface for presenting the algorithm
output and we deploy it like in the real
world in Wikipedia and to see how it
actually works so we work with Wikimedia
Foundation and the ways which we project
organizers to deploy our recruitment
systems and over a six month period we
evaluate over 16,000 answers and
delivered four distinct batches of 385
recommendations to 18 wiki project
and now we can evaluate these algorithms
so when we talk about the evaluation of
algorithms we first think about the
average and accuracy so usually this
evaluation algorithm primarily focused
on the accuracy however we think that
the accuracy is just one step towards
sir like a part
what's the on the path to where we want
to go it's not the end Coast so we think
that to fully understand the
effectiveness of recruitment system the
way we should also evaluate like
stakeholders acceptance especially in
the context of which period that people
tend to be really like feel strongly
about interventions and especially
intervention from the which people from
the research community so we want to
know whether these they could actually
accept our recruitment system ala and
and also we like did a seraph
evaluations on like the impact of these
recruitment systems are no stakeholders
so first talk about the evaluation of
the algorithm accuracy so we we compare
we look at like two accuracy murder one
is the average rating so remember in the
interface we have this short survey and
they can like a rate they like how good
they think the recommendation are like
five points like a scale and we also
look at the invitation rate so it's like
the proportion of the people of the
recommendations were like what act these
recommended antigen errors were actually
invited by the wiki project members so
the second one invitation rates is like
analogous to their click-through rate
yeah yeah yeah yeah we also track the
line going forward so which I will talk
a little bit like at the end so what we
found is that after they inviting with
the current project member members after
inviting these new members they will
actually continue to follow on like a
follow up with these new editors and
also questions and the actually provides
some like additional help to these
newcomers
after they invited
so what we have seen that actually the
row based algorithm which is the
simplest and most straightforward
algorithm is a performance best and the
the algorithm was the recommendation
were rated to higher and resulting in
like more invitations compared to the
other story types of algorithms and we
also actually specifically looking at
the experience the editors versus the
brand-new editors and we found that the
average rating and the invitation rate
were not that different were not
different between the experience editor
and the brand-new editors so this
suggests that our accuracy make a
recruitment tool is not disadvantaging
these brand new members which something
like a lot of other most traders really
care yeah great question yeah yeah so
the the threshold we define that brand
new is like saying made less than 100
edits like in Wikipedia as a whole so if
you make like from 1 to 100 no matter
how long they have joined so that's
another great question so we believe
that in ultra pedia the experience like
is accumulated by like actual editing so
if you like drawing for 10 years but you
only made like 10 edits they still make
you like a newbie because you still do
not know how exactly to navigate the
editing systems and how to interact with
other editors so we set up the threshold
100 this also is something we like a
talk with the Wikipedia like communities
that's actually they told us that's like
the community consensus about like the
brand new editor definitions
no question and so this is the like
evaluation of accuracy evaluation so the
next thing we evaluate is the
stakeholder acceptance so we interviewed
both the current project members and the
newcomers who invited to the projects
the feedback from the interview
participants was very positive they
actually gave us confidence that our a
recruitment system is really acceptable
to the communities so this is my
favorite quote from our current project
member and this editor said that this
put some signs behind the
recommendations and will be a great
supplement to the current processes so
this quote indicates that our - has a
potential to be well embedded into the
current recruitment process like
seamlessly embedded in town the process
for a lot of wiki project
and this is a quote from our new members
who are invited to join the project and
this minimizes thank you for reaching
out to me and thank you for informing me
about this wiki project Africa I
appreciate the order to receive some
feedback from the general QPD community
and we also create a sign post which is
Wikipedia the internal blog to describe
our project and this is a screenshot of
some of the comments like under our post
I'm not going to talk all the details
but in general the comments are very
positive like very interesting amazing
creation I'm really excited by the
potential for writing either toward
active subject focused working groups
so our collaborator Aaron half-acre who
is like a principal scientist at
Wikimedia Foundation and he told us that
this is really like seeing like such
like you animus lately like positive
response to things in which period
community because the Wikipedia
community tend to like disagree on
everything and we also found some
evidence that our project actually have
some good like some positive effects on
the relationship between there like
research community and the Wikipedia
community so actually this is screenshot
of some recent discussion around the
Wikipedia policy on Wikipedia is not a
laboratory
so this first address is that like
errors while using Wikipedia in any way
for experimentation
maybe bad so it's like feel very
strongly that you should yeah you should
not use these yeah so this now pause
this is a discussion like opinions so
this is some people they represent some
people inside communities like really
feel strongly that like a Wikipedia is
just a way to summarizing the exists
knowledge in the human knowledge is not
a way to create a new knowledge but then
there is another editor who responded
said there are a number of experiments
done in good faith to increase the
quality of the project or the experience
of editor the editor retention etc an
example the recent one is Bobo ostrich
which is my PhD student the wiki project
her recommendations so yeah I'm happy to
see that like our projects
to like become like a good examples of
like doing something like a research
community actually doing something
really good for the community we also
conducted in like a mixed-methods
evaluations on the impact of average a
Christmas to all some stakeholders so in
the interest of time I'm not going to
talk about all details so basically what
we found is that algorithms I how
everyone can identify newcomers who are
more suitable and the kind members did
additional investigations on our
accommodation and select is the most
promising newcomers this also means that
our a Christmas who might have like a
room for improvement so to reduce these
enters like efforts on the additional
investigations and some of the editors
project organize do complain with that
oh I spent too much time looking at all
the recommendations than me which
distracted me prevent me from doing
other more found things in Wikipedia and
there are also current members provide
additional help and the mentorship to
the invited newcomers which led to more
contributions from these new editors so
this is our evaluation of the accurate
three aspects of the a Christmas to all
and in sum we made these contributions
in this case study we generated this
knowledge of the stakeholder values
regarding intelligent recruitment system
in the context of Wikipedia we'll create
a four different algorithm for
identifying suitable new members and we
design and deploy the working systems in
the field and the evaluation showed that
the system is well accepted by the
community stakeholders will also
demonstrate the potential of a general
design process for incorporating these
stakeholders needs and values into the
creation of so next I will spend a
little bit time to talk about some of
our ongoing work on the AI based the
management or quality control system oh
I'll be very quick so basically the
Wikipedia nowadays are like starting to
adopting more and more AI to manage the
activities there were editors they use
the Krugman system is something we
created and we have the
have the evaluation system which I'm
going to talk about and they have the
regulation system and the task automated
task routing and assignment systems so
and we found this AI based management
system not just on Wikipedia we see that
these AI system like manipulate what the
post you see on Facebook it's basic
automatically identify and censor these
like unwanted contents like height
speech ratios the post and the these
algorithmic systems also manage like
people's activity are these like sharing
economy size like over lift and pasture
rabbit and a lot of people envision that
in future a lot of our like human
activities will eventually like be
managed by these algorithms intelligence
systems and BOTS so it's extremely
important to see how we can create this
like AI based management system means a
like a right way to like incorporate it
really reflected the respective people's
value and this is one of the like
ongoing project we do which is a merger
to redesign the machine learning based
the work evaluation system Wikipedia so
every day there are about 160,000 like a
new edits coming to like an English
Wikipedia alone and these all edits just
immediate goal life and the current
Wikipedia have this like machine
learning basic evaluation systems which
is the core of the system is the Auris
which is the prediction model to predict
the air quality and the the outcomes of
output of ours we'll be using a lot of
semi-automatic editing interfaces as
well as some like automated agents like
anti vandalism box and the the whole
system world like evaluate the quality
of the edits and then like take
corresponding actions like reverse
warning or reward so the challenge of
this machine on ebay evaluation system
in that first again it's actually
operated in diverse war context it had
been used in and vandalism using new
page patrolling also used for like a
Wikipedia education program to evaluate
these students contribution and in each
case we see different stakeholders and
there is page
between different stakeholders values
for example some people like some like
stakeholders value quality control they
want to catch all the possible
potentially like damaging edits but
there is other like stakeholder more
value like member protections they don't
want to falsely accuse any like
well-intentioned editors and again there
are like fairness and accuracy like
trade-off so Oris has been like already
like a received reports that there are
systems so the evaluation systems were
bias against anonymous editors and but
we know that once we like improve beta
so the accuracy would drop so there are
a lot of tensions between like different
goals so that's the one of the current
projects and with Steven rule here and
we want to handle the great ways to
handle these inherent trade-offs between
different stakeholders goals in this
machine learning based evaluation
systems and this we recently received
some good news about like our grants are
recommended for funding yeah and the
whole idea is like we're trying to see
first like again we talk to the
stakeholders I understand their goals
and then work with them to formulate and
then to define their goals and I'm not
going to go into details and then we
want to capture the trade-off so we're
going to work together to create a
family of models with a spectrum of
trial trade-offs and then we can present
all of these models to the stakeholders
but we use the way no more technologies
to realize the trade-offs to allow
people to navigate the all these
hundreds of different models and
identify this trade-off and eventually
help them to like a negotiate and find
the solutions to balance with different
stakeholders trade-offs
so that's er again we think that we want
to create like empirical knowledge no
more technologies and like novo
socio-technical solutions to balance
difference the trade-off between
different stakeholder goals
so this is some like we actually talk
about how the applications on the
algorithmic content curation after a lot
of social media sites are trying to use
these algorithmic system to
automatically identifying the since
they're like a hate speech I love
countering the misinformation racist
sexist ads and so forth just an example
of a recent like like a christmas system
down like a tumblr and how it actually
falsely flag a lot of like non-sexual
like on like a random poster as like a
doll contents and this but this is an
interesting question because there are a
lot of inherent trade-offs on how you
define these hate speeches and adult
content like there is tensions between
different stakeholders values and
different goals which potentially we are
is something we trying to address in the
wikipedia contacts and we can apply this
here so yeah so I guess the big picture
thing is yeah I guess the whole idea is
to this is the final slides so well yeah
integrate a wide range of human needs
and values including famously in the
design of these AI technologies with a
broader goals to improve people's lives
and accomplish in these collective goals
and I think it's important to have like
these inter interdisciplinary like
efforts presume there is a lot of
opportunities for the collaborations
between the FASTA like ml community and
HCI and we are the kind of people who
actually go to talk to to work with the
real people in real system and then we
can like actually work with machine
learning researchers to identify like
province and then I think it's important
to have the partnership industry and
it's there is also opportunity to create
these general methods that can like do
you achieve these goals okay so and
thank you for listen to my talk and I'm
happy to answer a question I don't know
if we have time
[Applause]
is there a quick explanation why the
room gets out of it actually
yeah yeah that's a great question so
actually one thing I think is really
they can understand through the rule
based algorithm so the onus is the fact
that they can understand this like they
seemed to like it makes them like trust
of the results more yeah so there is a
trade-off of understandability and maybe
the accuracy
procedural justice and algorithmic
fairness transparency control and
participations perspective by me you
mean from particular